okay thank you very much and and thank
you all for sticking around and
thank you uh rick and steve for for
getting us together for this uh
i think rather inspiring meeting so so i
want to tell you a little bit about our
recent work on fitness landscapes and i
sort of try to emphasize in the spirit
of this workshop
some of the uh interesting probabilistic
aspects
of this problem um this is work that has
been funded by the german science
foundation within two
collaborative projects one based in
biology and the other one which is
perhaps more interesting in this context
it's called probabilistic structures and
evolution and it's actually funded by
the mathematics section
of the dfg so i want to do basically
three things here i want to
introduce to you to the problem of
fitness landscapes and one of the
reasons why people are now interested in
this again
is uh the is an empirical reason so
there's much more empirical data now
than there used to be so i'll talk
about that a little bit i will then
focus on what we call accessible
mutational pathways which are
essentially pathways
in a fitness landscape that are
monotonically increasing in fitness
and if there is time i will talk at the
end also about adaptive walks which
which give you a kind of sort of more
dynamical view
of how populations actually evolve in
these landscapes
now a talk on fitness landscapes
basically has to start with
a sewell wright who introduced this
notion in 1932
and who introduced it mainly to make
clear that in his view of evolution
there's a problem uh with with um
many uh that evolutionary problems
typically have many solutions which can
be viewed as peaks in the fitness
landscape and there's an evolutionary
problem to understand
how you get from one peak to the other
how you can cross valleys
and this eventually led to the
development of the
right shifting balance theory
now in this in this 1932 paper there
were two illustrations
one is is what is an illustration of the
space of genotypes to the extent that it
was known to write
and you see here in these pictures there
is always a wild type which is this
cross and then you have mutations so in
this case there is a mutant at locus a
and the mutation of locus b and then you
have the double mutant
here we have three mutants which then
make up three mutations which make up a
little cube and so on
so wright of course was very much aware
that that the space of genotypes
is a discrete space and it has a
structure of a hypercube
now to sort of make things more more um
easy to understand for for for his
audience
he also included this picture which is a
kind of two-dimensional cartoon of a
landscape with peaks and valleys
and and i think it's fair to say that
historically the second picture is
really what has survived so this is what
you will still find in a lot of biology
textbooks and also in many talks at
evolution conferences
but of course it's misleading in many
ways because the geometry of the
hypercube is very different
from the geometry of the plane and this
is something that i will
will try to emphasize in this talk
so so let me introduce the mathematical
setting which is basically the setting
that i showed you
in the illustration on the previous
slide so we're going to treat genotypes
as binary sequences of some fixed length
l um there is a there are binary which
basically means that on every
site you'd only care if you have the
resident the wild type or the
the mutant allele and you can
think of these as being sequences
composed of zero one or minus one and
one
and there's some reason you know to
prefer one or the other i'll mention
that
a little bit later and the fitness
landscape is then simply a function on
that space
and and which is which is a measure of
reproductive success of the organism's
mean number of offspring or something
like that
now the notion of epistasis which has
come up a few times
during this conference and also today in
this context simply means
that there are interactions between the
effects of different mutations
in on fitness and so
this essentially means that any function
f of sigma
which is not additive in the
contributions from the different sigmas
is an epistetic fitness function so
you can you can argue about whether you
should use additive or multiplicative as
null model
but if you use multiplicative then you
can take the log and then you have
additive again so that doesn't make much
of a difference
the main thing is that of course you
know most functions by nature have to be
epistetic
and therefore epistasis is expected to
be something that is very
very common now there's a particular
kind of epistasis that is important in
this context
which is called synaptostasis and this
is a notion that to my knowledge was
introduced by dan weinreich and
collaborators
so synapostasis means that the mutation
at a given locus can be beneficial that
that is increasing fitness or
deleterious depending on the background
that is depending on the state of other
loci
and this is illustrated here for the
case of two loci
so if you do a mutation at the first
locus from
from zero to one where the second locus
is zero you see that fitness goes down
so it's a deleterious mutation but if
you perform the same
mutation on the background of the one
locus at the second side you see that
mutation go
the fitness goes up so this is where
this is sine epistasis and since this is
true for both loci
this is called reciprocal sine epistasis
and what you can see is that reciprocal
synapostasis
gives rise to multi-peaked fitness
landscapes which is not a theorem but
you know it's it's we'll i'll mention
that a little bit later
so so cyan epistasis gives rise to
ruggedness of fitness landscapes and
that's that's the reason why it's
important
um so um okay so this is just again
emphasizing that the space that that
we're looking at is
is this hypercube and this is what these
hypercubes look like
as you as you increase the number of
dimensions
um so how can you sort of how can you
sort of quantify
the the the the amount and the kind of
epistasis in the fitness landscape
i already mentioned the fitness peaks
that
um that right worried about so obviously
you can count local optima so optimum is
simply
a site where fitness is larger than all
one mutant neighbor so i should say i
didn't mention that but of course you
have you know as a sort of natural
distance measure on the hypercube you
just have single mutations
and with respect to that distance
measure this is the definition of a
maximum
if there's no sign episodes is it easy
to show that there's a single optimum
only
and on the other hand it's known that
reciprocal sine epistasis is a necessary
condition for the existence of multiple
peaks but is in fact not a sufficient
condition so this has been shown in some
recent papers
now in in this talk i want to i want to
mostly look at a different notion a
different
quantifier of of fitness landscape
ruggedness
which is based on this notion of
selectively accessible path introduced
by vine rice
where we say that a path connecting to
genotypes
where the initial genotype has lower
fitness and the than the
final one is called selectively
accessible if fitness increases
monotonically along the path so this is
sort of a notion that is based on the
um on the idea that that you're in some
sort of strong selection wheat mutation
regime
where mutations can only fix if they are
beneficial and then
a population can can sort of evolve
along such
a path only if it's monotonically
increasing and a nice feature of this no
this notion is that there's a one-to-one
correspondence
with the existence of synaptostasis so
if there are sign epistasis then
uh there at least there are some paths
to the global maximum
that are not accessible and vice versa
okay which
was also approved by weinreich and
collaborators
there's a third kind of somewhat
different kind of quantification of
epistasis that i want to
mention here also because it's something
that sort of
links this field somewhat to computer
science i think so this is a
so basically the idea is that you can
expand any fitness function on the
hypercube
uh in in in
interactions of different orders where
you have sort of the non-epistetic
linear part here and the rest are then
the epistatic parts
and in fact if you choose these sigmas
to be plus and minus one
then this is in fact an expansion in
orthogonal in orthogonal functions
which are eigenfunctions of the graph
laplacian on the hypercube and they are
called walsh functions in computer
science
so this sort of a nice you know way of
representing
uh the the interactions and then you can
sort of sum interactions of different
orders
and then you get something that we call
a fourier spectrum which
which tells you how much weight there is
in the different
uh in the different orders of
interactions and in particular you can
sort of sum all the weights
of interactions of order two and greater
and that gives you a kind of number
that tells you how much epistasis there
is in this in this
landscape okay so i mentioned that that
a lot of this recent work
in this field has been has been driven
by by empirical advances and so i want
to show you at least one
example of an empirical fitness
landscape
so this is from our own work this is a
these are
data that were collected or or generated
by aryan difficult
for fungus aspergillus niger so
this is a data set that contains
combinations of eight individually
deleterious marker mutations
and what you're seeing here is sort of a
five-dimensional subset of this
eight-dimensional
landscape and the way it's represented
so you have these genotypes which have
zeros on one so the all zeros is the
wild type
which in this case has the highest
fitness because there are no deleterious
mutations
and so here you have these 32 different
combinations this is the five-fold
mutant
and the arrows only always point in the
direction of increasing fitness
and so you see for example here there
are three local maxima where all the
arrows are pointing inward
and if you count how many of the paths
from here to there are accessible
so they're all together 5 factorial or
120
you'll find that 25 are accessible and
the others are not okay so this is sort
of
the kind of data set um that that
one can look at and one can analyze it
in various ways so just an example this
is the fourier spectrum of that
landscape
and so these are the interactions of
different orders this is the
non-epistatic piece
and these are the epistatic parts and
this dashed line is what you would get
if you assume that fitness were random
so this is what we call the house of
cards model
so if you just distribute the fitness
values at random
on the on the hypercube this is what you
get and so you see that
this part looks rather random but
there's a kind of enhancement in the
second order interactions for this
particular landscape
so by now there are about 20 of these
data sets
for different organisms and we published
last year we published a kind of
meta analysis of these empirical data
sets
and i just want to briefly mention it
here so this is sort of a list of the
the
so 10 data sets we analyze in this in
this particular paper
um and they are partly these are
mutations uh that are in the genome of
entire organisms so there are two
bacterial species here
this is this aspergillus niger data set
that i just mentioned this one down here
is actually nine dimensional
and it has this is from a plant enzyme
and there are some but there are also
data sets that look at single genes in
particular model system here
is the beta lactamase enzyme which which
confers antibiotic resistance to e coli
so you see the sizes are between five
and eight four and eight
there are sort of different fitness
proxies that that people have measured
and these can be beneficial or
deleterious mutations and they have been
selected either for combined or
individual effects
so so basically we have a kind of
toolbox of epistasis measures
that we can calculate for all these
landscapes and then you can so one of
the things that we were interested
in here was to see whether um
whether these different measures in some
sense measure the same thing
and this is illustrated here so this is
these plots
compare different epistasis measures
some of which i have introduced others
not
so for example and max down here is the
number of of maxima in the landscape
and and up here is the number what we
call the number of crossing paths so
these are these accessible pathways
and these different letters correspond
to letters in this table so you see here
that
that um sorry um that
that you know they are sort of arranged
in a certain way
and one of the things that you should
notice is that
if you if you sort of order these
different data sets according to how
rugged the landscape is they typically
tend to
uh align in the same way so for example
this a landscape
is typically a is very smooth in fact
this is a landscape that doesn't have
any synapse stasis so out of those 10
data sets i think it's the only one
that doesn't display synapstesis so
there's only one maximum
and all the pathways are accessible the
b landscape is a
little bit rougher the the aspergillus
landscape is g is up here
which is typically rather rough and so
you see so the main thing here is that
these sort of
the way these symbols fall in in this
plane is
is more or less consistent between
different pairs of measures
and you also see a line now this line is
calculated with a model
so so the other thing that we wanted to
know was whether it's possible to
somehow
uh you know parameterize these data sets
using
some simple models and this is actually
a parameterization
by this whole called rough mount fuji
model which i will introduce in a moment
um and and so you although of course you
know these these points don't really
fall on on that line although
all the time but you can see that the
overall trends are fairly well
represented by this model
which sort of interpolates between a
limit of a smooth landscape
and a maximally rough landscape which is
the landscape where you pick
all the all the um
fitness values at random okay can you
just
say um is it easy to say quickly what
you do when you've got missing data i
noticed on
yes okay that's a very good point so so
basically
um yeah so so you typically so these up
here are all complete but these ones
they are missing data so in the
aspergillus niger case because you know
we
we know we we collaborate with with the
person who actually got the data and so
we have the raw data
so there we actually convinced ourselves
that the missing data presumably had
fitness zero
so we assigned fitness zero to them we
estimated that it's very unlikely that
we have
missed them for statistical reasons in
this data set this is not so clear
so actually what we did there in order
to analyze it because for some of the
analysis you need to complete it
for example in order to calculate this
fourier spectrum
um and so so there we we did
we we basically did a kind of linear
interpolation so we fitted we fitted a
linear model
to the uh to the um to the to the
incomplete set
and then then use that to sort of fill
in which of course makes it a little bit
smoother but in principle
these are the you know two things that
you can do and sort of interpolating
based on how far away things are
in having a distance in some sense well
i think we basically just
we fitted a linear model and then we
just took the the the fitness values
predicted by the linear model
the sort of input is fitting you use
fitness as a kind of like neighbors
in a sense you would weight that more
heavily than fitnesses
no i think well i think we just take the
linear i mean the linear model has like
nine coefficients
and then we just you know calculate the
fitness from the linear model
so we assume so and that and so that
that that sort of
in some sense implies that there's less
episodes
in presence in absence yes yes exactly
exactly
yes yes that's right yeah yeah
right yeah but this is of course and i
should say you know one of them i think
the the
important problems here is how do you
get from these sizes
you know to thousands or tens of
thousands of loci and in that situation
of course you'll have lots and lots of
missing data
so these statistical issues i think are
are very important and are sort of
beginning to be addressed but but i'm
not going to to really mention them here
okay so um other other questions at this
point
okay so let me let me go on to the to
the modeling part so so
we're looking at in order to describe
these data sets and also to learn more
more generally about um about these
landscapes
we look at models which which i call
random field models so this is a term
introduced by peter startler
and it just means that you have some
probabilistic setting in which you
assign fitness values
to the genotypes and the simplest way of
doing that
is to just fitness science fitness at
random okay and this is what we call the
house of cards model
a term that was introduced by kingman in
a slightly different setting but this
model really
i think was studied first by kaufman and
levine in 1987.
and so so the nice thing about the house
of cards model is that you can do some
stuff
analytically so in particular there's a
simple
combinatorial argument telling you
something about the selectively
accessible path so let's suppose i'm at
a distance hamming distance d
from the global optimum in my landscape
and i want to know what is the expected
number of
direct selectively accessible paths so a
direct path is one that approaches the
maximum by one step
each in each with each mutation of
course the total number of such path is
d
factorial and each of these along each
of these paths you will encounter d
fitness values so f 0 is the first one d
minus one is the one before the optimum
and then of course you have the the
optimum which is sort of which you know
is already is the global maximum so the
path is
accessible if these random numbers are
uh in in ascending order and so since
all permutations of these random
variables are equally likely in this
model the probability
that a particular path will be
accessible as one over d factorial
and so since our d factorial path the
expected number of path is actually one
so this is sort of you know a very
simple argument which i should
shamefully must must admit we've
discovered numerically but once you
understand where it comes from
uh it's not so so hard but i think it's
sort of interesting and it's maybe and
it's this is independent of the distance
so you know where however far you are
this will always be true and this holds
in particular
for the longest path which are at
distance l okay
now you might think that this this means
that it's easy to find this path
but but this is in fact this this
result is in some sense very misleading
uh
because if you look at the distribution
of the number of path which we did
numerically in this paper
it has a very peculiar shape so this is
the the probability
of finding an accessible path for
different sizes of the hypercube from
five to nine and you see it has a big
peak at zero so so the most likely
uh realization is that there's no path
and then there's a fairly long tail
and together these two things sort of
combine to always give you a mean of one
okay so that tells you
that this is a widely fluctuating
quantity and the distribution is clearly
not well characterized
by the mean so you need at least one
other quantity and so we like to look at
what we call the accessibility so this
is simply the probability that there is
at least one path
right so one minus pll zero is the
accessibility
and so pl of zero is plotted here in the
inset so this is the probability that
there is no path
for the house of cards model and you see
that this tends to appears to be
approaching one in the limit of large l
which means that in a large hypercube
you will not
with probability one you will not have
such a path and this was actually
subsequently proof i'll come to that on
the next slide
but i also want to mention the the
second plot here
which says constrained house of cards
model so constrained here means is the
version of the model
that was introduced by carneiro and
hartel and there the idea is that you
you you um you constrain the what we
call the reversal genotype that is the
point
opposite to the um to the to the maximum
to have the smallest fitness right so
basically
you know if you want to want to realize
that you can just um
so this is our hypercube
um so here we have let's say this is the
maximum
and i want this to be the minimum so one
layer for example of
of um realizing that is to assign
zero fitness uh here and fitness one
here and and to distribute all the other
ones uniformly between zero and one
okay now so so this so this obviously
makes the first step a lot easier
because
you always know that the first step will
be possible but what is surprising is
that it has a very
strong global effect and in fact so this
is a probability that there is no path
in the constrained model
and you see that it actually seems to be
going down again
and so this actually this was a an
observation that that
mo has motivated uh some some
mathematical work that i want to mention
in particular by peter
hegarty and anders martinez on this is a
paper that is
in press in the annals of applied
probability
so what they could prove is that there's
a kind of percolation phenomenon here so
if you
fix the fitness of the initial genotype
to be f0
then if f0 is is larger than log l over
l
then the the this accessibility will
tend to zero that you will that is you
will with probability one not find a
path
but if it's smaller than log l over l
particularly if it's zero which is the
case in this in this constrain model
then it will tend to one okay and of
course in particular if you don't
constrain the initial fitness
then this is just the probability of
finding a path
and so this tells you that this will
approach unity
as log l over l now very recently
julia berestitsky and and collaborators
in paris
have extended this analysis to including
also backstep so suppose you allow for
the path to not
always always go towards the maximum but
also to go back
this makes a problem in some sense much
harder so it's not even possible
in closed form to count the number of
paths in that way in that sense
in that setting but but what they what
they were able to show
at least as a bound and they conjecture
this to be exact is that then the
accessibility threshold actually becomes
independent of l so so so there's a
finite even for a large l
um there's a finite probability of of
finding a path
to the global maximum if you allow the
path to have backsteps
and uh this problem has also been
analyzed on on
on on on trees by by asan by by others
and so on the tree you can sort of think
of trees
where you where you scale the the
branching number and you scale the depth
of the tree
and in order to sort of model the
hypercube you should scale the two in
the same way because the hypercube has a
sort of branching number and the depth
that are the same
and so if you do that so if you scale h
if you if you fix h over b
and you take h and b to infinity then it
turns out that there is again a kind of
accessibility threshold
which is at e okay so when this is 2.7
then you go from having with probability
one having no path to having a path with
probability one
okay so this is very nice but of course
the model this house of cards model is
not
uh really realistic if you look at the
at the data
so there's clearly a need for for models
that that have you know intermediate
ruggedness
and so there's been some interest also
in
in these tunably rugged models in
particular kaufman's nk
model should be mentioned here and i'll
talk about that a little bit more
um so i guess many of you are sort of
familiar with this model
so there um you basically assume that
each locus interacts randomly with
with k other loci and so you have a
locus and its neighborhood
and within that set of k plus one loci
you again assign fitness at random okay
so this interpolates between the
non-epistetic and the house of cards
model
the other is the raf mount fuji model
that i already mentioned that was
in the uh introduced by aita at al
recently and we just published it or or
submitted an
extensive analysis of that of that model
where you basically you you define some
sort of a reference sequence
sigma zero and then you say fitness is
is varies linearly with distance from
that reference sequence
and then there's also a random component
so this is an iid random variable
theta is a parameter and when theta
becomes large the landscape becomes
smoother
and so for that case actually hegarty
and martinson were able to prove
that this accessibility
converges to one for any positive theta
so as soon as you put a little bit of of
this linear piece
uh the the um these uh landscapes become
accessible but i want to talk about this
model anymore in the in the remainder of
the talk i want to
focus on the nk model because it has i
guess what um
to my mind a little bit more of what
what daniel fischer the other
they call the smell of biology i mean
it's not a lot of smell of biology but a
little bit
in the sense that in this model you can
implement something
that is somewhat reminiscent of genetic
architecture in the following sense so
so i said
uh before that that here you know you
let each locus interact with l minus
one other loci but you have to of course
define what these low psi
are right and there are sort of
different schemes in which you can do
that
so the most commonly used version is i
think the random choice so here these
arrows just indicate so this locus i
so in this case locus i receives sort of
input
in its in its fitness contribution from
locus one
and from locus j uh and locus j maybe in
receives input from this one and this
one so you basically choose your
interaction partners at random
among the other loci so this is the
random version but of course you can
also do this in a kind of
one-dimensional way
and always choose sites which are
adjacent along the sequence and finally
you can do it in a kind of modular way
that is you subdivide
your sequence into into parts into
blocks and within each block everybody
interacts with everybody else and
between blocks there are no interactions
and so it's sort of an interesting
question which properties of the fitness
landscape actually depend on this choice
so suppose i fix k
i fix l um and i i vary this genetic
architecture
and this is a a problem where there are
some you know some some
results are known so in particular if
you look at the fitness correlation
function so just fitness fitness
correlation function as a function of
distance
this turns out to be manifestly
independent of the neighborhood scheme
i should warn you that there are some a
number of papers in the in the
literature which claim that this is not
true but but the
the most recent one is actually has
settled that so this is uh
this is certainly true and this implies
in particular also that the fourier
spectrum is independent of of the
of the genetic architecture
but for other properties this is this is
less clear so in particular
the block model which was introduced by
perrelson and mackin in 1995
is is nice because you can calculate
things analytically and you can in
particular calculate the expected number
of maxima
and if you now compare that and there's
been some rigorous work by
by rick durrett and others on
on the number on the asymptotic
properties of the number of maxima
and so if you compare this expression to
the rigorous results for the adjacent
model you find that they're very close
they're not the same
right so so there are clear differences
but but
so so our experience also with the
number of accessible path that i will
get to
is that sort of with regard to average
properties
the genetic architecture doesn't seem to
matter a whole lot but with regard to
fluctuations it appears to be very
important
so we have looked at at this problem of
accessible path in the block model
and we derived this expression for it
and i'm just
briefly going to explain to you how that
works so the basic
idea is that in the block model
any path can be decomposed into a sub
path
which are within one block so every time
you do a step in a path you change one
locus
this locus will be in one block and the
other contributions will not change
right so only one of the contributions
in your sum will change and so and
obviously if you want the path as a
whole
to be monotonically increasing then the
condition for that is that all these
sub-paths are monotonically increasing
as well
and so that means that a given pathway
spanning the whole landscape is
accessible if all the sub path within
the blocks are accessible
and so so you need you need all these
pathways to be accessible but then you
can sort of combine them in different
ways so there's a combinatorial factor
which tells you how many in how many
ways you can combine the sub path
and therefore the number of blocks the
number of path in the full model is just
the product over the number of
paths in the blocks times this factor
and since
within the so each block is a is a house
of cards model so within each block
fitness values are iid random variables
so if you take the expectation
the expectation here is one um and so
you find that the expected number of
blocks is
this this quantity which is actually
very fastly quickly increasing
um for any k which is not equal to l
minus one so as soon as the landscape is
not completely random
the expected number of path will be very
large
at the same time you can also calculate
the accessibility so the probability
that you will find such a path is equal
to the probability that you find it in
the blocks
to the power of the number of blocks and
since this is a number that whatever it
is is
between zero and one you see that if you
keep k fixed and you take l to infinity
the probability of finding this path
will actually go to zero so so this is a
rather extreme case
of this of this property of these
pathways that i or
the the pathway statistics that i
mentioned which is that
the expected number uh becomes very
large but the probability to find
at least one path goes to zero right so
which tells you that there are
a few exceptional landscapes which are
highly accessible but most of them are
not accessible at all
so this is now comparing different uh
neighborhood schemes
um for the so this is the mean number of
accessible path versus l
and the colors different colors
correspond to different values of k and
the different symbols correspond to
random adjacent and block models
and you see that the the symbols are
very close to each other so so basically
that tells you that just as for the
number of maxima
with regard to the mean number of path
it doesn't the genetic architecture
doesn't matter
but if you now look at the accessibility
so the probability of finding at least
one path
you see that for the block model which
are these pluses this goes down very
rapidly we know that it goes down
exponentially and we can calculate the
rate when
when k is sufficiently small but for
some of the other versions it actually
goes up so this is for example the
random model
for k equal to three it seems that
accessibility becomes large
right so so it seems that the um at
least and i should say this is and this
is even more pronounced if you go to
larger k
um but i should say this is for system
sizes that that can be simulated
we have reasons to believe at least for
a small k
that eventually this will go back down
to zero but we have no so we're trying
to prove that at the moment but but we
have no way of of sort of
at this point to estimate where that
actually happens and whether this is in
a sort of reasonable
range or not okay so so
in the last couple of minutes let me let
me say a few things about
adaptive walks so so so far i have i
have looked at these landscapes from a
sort of purely structural point of view
so we just asked you know are there
paths that can take me to the maximum
this is of course
if you look at the reality this is a
somewhat academic question because the
question is not whether they are these
paths but whether an
evolving adapting population can
actually find them
and so the adaptive walks models are you
know somewhat more realistic
in that in that sense so what is an
adaptive walk-in adaptive walk is a
markov chain
on sequence space that so you have a you
know you assume your population is
monomorphic which is true for small
enough mutation rates
and it's constrained to move to genome
types of at large of larger fitness so
you move uphill according to some sort
of
stochastic algorithm and you terminate
if you reach a local maximum
now there are sort of three flavors of
these walks
um one that that i call the random
adaptive walk
where all you just you in every step you
just choose one of the fitter genotypes
at random
there's a greedy adaptive walk where you
always choose the most fit one
okay so then you it's a sort of a
steepest ascent
and then there's this what i call the
true adaptive walk this is the one that
was introduced by gillespie
and this is sort of the one that
actually comes out of the population
genetics background
um so there so if you if you do say the
right fischer model and you analyze it
for
uh weak mutation strong selection you
find that the transition rate is
proportional to the to the fixation rate
which is proportional to the fitness
difference
between the resident and the mutant
genotype so here actually the transition
probability depends in a somewhat
non-trivial way
on on your environment so these are sort
of three versions and the the quantities
that have been of interest in the past
is mostly the length so people wanted to
know how far do you
you know go before you reach a maximum
but i think also an interesting question
which i think hasn't received much
attention is the
achieved fitness so how far do you
actually get you know that you will end
up at a maximum
but of course these maxima are not
arbitrary maxima but they are maxima
that have been selected by the process
right now again
most of the work has been done in house
of cards landscapes
and here if you look at the random and
the greedy cases those are fully
determined by the rank
ordering of the fitness landscape so you
don't don't actually have to worry about
the distribution of the fitness values
and there there are so there are a
number of results so fluid big and loud
trip showed
that the length of these walks is
proportional is is log l
plus some constant where l is now i mean
l is a dimensionality but it's really
the number of uphill directions that you
have initially i mean you don't really
have to care about the part of the
genotype
which is not uphill um so so so it's log
l so it's you know
it's very short i mean the the these
accessible pathways that i described to
you previously have length l
but here we see that typically you only
get up to distance log l
and if you're greedy you actually get
much less far you only get to distance
1.7 so this is a nice result by ore
now in the true adaptive walk things are
a little bit more complicated so there
the distribution actually matters and we
showed some years ago
that it's still log l but there's a
coefficient that depends on the
extreme value index so for the
mathematicians i should say these are so
in particular
a rather complete derivation has been
given by kavita jain but this is
certainly not a proof so this is sort of
you know for a mathematical purpose as a
conjecture
and what you can sort of see is that
this true adaptive walk becomes
effectively random
if you make uh if you make the
distribution
uh if you push the distribution deeply
into the bible class and it becomes
greedy if you if you push it deeply into
the frechet class which is sort of
also what you expect um
if you look at uh yeah well okay yes i
mean there is an issue here
whether you should maintain the uh the
assumption that the
transition probability is proportional
to the fitness differences this is what
we assume here but this may not be
the right thing to do i agree yeah
right so so what about the height so
this is a very recent result by stefan
novak
uh where where he looked at the walk
height in the house of cards
model right so we know that this the um
the walks the random walks are log l and
the greedy walks or have length 1.7
and so what stefan uh was able to show
that
uh if you if you look so you know just
for for concreteness say we choose the
fitness values
uniformly then of course a generic
maximum
will have value will have a value
1 minus 1 over l right now here it turns
out
that these random adaptive walks do a
little bit better so they go up to level
beta or one minus beta over l where beta
is this number
which which you can express in terms of
of an integral but the greedy walks
actually do even better
and so they come up to a level of one
minus 4.4 over l
and again so these are sort of constants
that you can write down as series or
integrals
um and and so this is more or less an an
exact result which i
i found somewhat i mean you know from
the outset i wouldn't have known which
way to to to guess
right i mean is is greedy adaptation
better given that that it's you know it
these walks are so short it's not
obvious at all that they really uh
get get further um
now what about the length so so uh
stefan has also
looked about looked at uh walk length in
in nk
landscapes again here the block model is
easy because the walk length is additive
so we have an explicit expression
for the walk length in the block model
which is shown here by these
by these red symbols this is the greedy
case so this is now the walk length
divided by l over k
this this coefficient here and so what
you see here is that
the other uh so the architecture matters
a little bit
and the random for in the random
randomly connected nk model the walks
are typically a bit longer
than in the in the in the block model
but again it's not not
um the the difference is not dramatic
and again you can also look at the walk
height and this is i think rather again
rather surprising
so this now the fitness difference
between a greedy walk
and a random walk at the at the final
point
and you see that um it's for the block
model it's always positive just like in
the house of cards model
but for the random model it seems to be
sort of non-monotonic so it actually
for intermediate k it seems that the
random walks are doing better than the
greedy ones
so i don't i don't really know what that
means um i thought i don't know if there
are still any computer scientists in the
audience but
but i i feel that this is something that
computer scientists probably know
something about
okay so let me let me um conclude
uh so i've shown you uh some examples of
empirical fitness landscapes and they
provide some insights into the patterns
of epistasis we have uh looked at the
these random landscape models and i
think these landscape models beyond
their sort of mathematical interests
are also really useful to to develop
some intuition
for what you should expect to to happen
when the the dimensionality of the
genotype space becomes very large right
because there's
this is a problem that is hard to
explore experimentally it's also hard to
explore computationally but perhaps
mathematically one can
one can do something here and so we have
some results but
as i said the the conclusion is not so
clear-cut it sort of depends on what
what measure of accessibility you
actually look at
and at the end i i gave you some results
for these um
adaptive walks which sort of complement
the view of landscape structure
in terms of a dynamic point of view and
finally i want to acknowledge my
collaborators so this is a group in
cologne
students and postdocs and in particular
also i want to acknowledge
ariana fisher our experimental
collaborator at the university of vahani
so thank you
there's a clear connection i mean so the
obviously i mean in the so in the spin
glass context
uh you know these these accessible
pathways are essentially zero
temperature trajectories is sort of what
we're looking at right so if you do sort
of zero so this random adaptive walk is
exactly
a zero temperature metropolis dynamics
um
and so you know i sort of i've talked to
spin glass people we haven't really
there hasn't been a point at this so far
where where you know it's been
really useful to sort of transfer
concepts uh
the the the ex the the satisfiability
problems i think
uh are should give you some
possibly some insight into these nk
models because in some sense
the clauses so you know if you sort of
add clauses
then uh this is sort of similar to
adding these different terms
uh in in the nk model so i'm you know
i'm certainly aware of that connection
but
it hasn't from for for our work it
hasn't been
turned out to be productive but that's
maybe only because i haven't been able
to get the right people interested in
this
stuff so yeah
so going back to the
early part of the talk where you talked
about these empirical fitness landscapes
i sort of find these things interesting
but also don't fight what to make of
them when thinking about how they might
or might not generalize
to you know landscapes involving
thousands of both sides
do you have like i mean what would you
do if you could do it
given that you obviously cannot
construct
anything near a complete fitness
landscape
do you have any thoughts on like what
should people measure to try to
characterize
these much larger landscapes yeah so
what people have started to do so there
you know there are a few papers
that have tried to um analyze
sort of large-scale data sets um
in in this landscape context and one of
the things that that they do
which i think is is sort of a nice
approach so so basically you know so you
know
that your landscape has has its
decomposition but of course this has
you know this has two to the l
coefficients so if you want to have all
the coefficients you need all the you
know it's the same problem as having all
the data
but so what what people have done and
there is a paper by the bonhoeffer group
that that does this for
for hiv genotypes and there's a more
recent one by artwinovsky and neyman
who have done this for the for the lack
promoter i think
um is is that you try so you know more
more sort of
modestly you could try to estimate
second order effects because they are
you know they're sort of uh they're only
l square
second order coefficients so and and so
this is what people have done so they
have you know tried to fit
a quadratic model and then you can
either say well
you know maybe higher order effects are
not important or maybe one can try to
estimate
the higher order effects or maybe one
one
just takes the this quadratic landscape
as it is and then you can try to analyze
its properties
you know see how rugged is it are there
many maxima and so on
um i have a question about i mean let's
imagine that you had
a thousand loci and there were only
fifth order effects
there were no for there were no
secondary or fourth order
and you did what you're suggesting you
would find something that fit
pretty well with only second order
effects wouldn't you yes
so it seems a little frustrating yeah
sure but
you know i think this is sort of i mean
this is what what people are trying to
do i'm not sure if if
it's if and i think it's an interesting
question you know to try to understand
uh uh how well is that expected to work
and
and there's a recent preprint by by
otvanovsky and plotkin where they sort
of try to
you know compare different models uh
with regard to this
this this sort of this bias that you
just mentioned so if you have the wrong
model
you know how how well can you do and so
on but i think this is sort of the
direction in which things are moving i'm
not sure
uh you know what what what the um
conclusions will be at the end in the
end but but i think it's
uh yeah it's worth trying
yeah so the the fourier expansion
suggests
uh you know another model for landscapes
which is that you know you just
take the the coefficients in the
expansion
as being you know say independent
variables
with maybe you know just the
distribution depending on
what the level of interaction is right
has anybody
sort of looked at models like that and
been able to sort of compute
anything about them in terms of but of
course this is basically so if you
truncate that second order this is a
spin glass this is sort of the sheraton
patrick spinglass model right of course
with random fields
now i should but and people have looked
at spin glass
landscapes in this context so i should
but i should say if you
you know an important difference between
spin glass models and
and and k models for example is that in
the nk model by the way it's constructed
uh these coefficients are rather sparse
so many of them are zero
and this is maybe what you would also
hope to be true for biological data i
think there is in the ottuvinovsky data
set there is some indication
that you know if you because you always
you have all these coefficients and so
if you sort of over
you know have that problem overfitting
and you can try to suppress the small
small effects and then you get something
that is farce whereas of course in the
certain kirkpatrick spin glass
these would be gaussian random variables
so they would all be of a similar size
and also in the spin glass context
people have looked at what they call
p-spin models
where you instead of having quadratic
interactions you have
uh interactions of order p uh i think
this was was done by by the reader
so in that in that setting you know this
is a model
people have worked with these kinds of
models and of course they are
um i should say that the you know the
the the
reason i mean the the fact that the nk
model is
is becoming popular again is maybe also
more historical i mean it's not not
necessarily the case that it's more
realistic than say assuring
patrick spinglass but i feel that having
something that is sparse is probably
going to be useful especially with
regard to this proliferation of
coefficients
yeah are you aware of any work on um
modeling these edges so they accommodate
say weekly deleterious effects
so so this it seems like if you had this
strictly increasing sequence of
fitnesses
yeah then that that has an implicit
assumption about population science
that's right it might be that if you
have smaller population sizes some of
these edges can be traversable
well you have to in fact you have two
effects i mean so at smaller population
sizes you might be able to traverse
weekly
deleterious links but of course at very
large population sizes you have clonal
interference and then you will be able
to tunnel through valleys
so that also and this we have sort of
investigated in simulation so we have
done simulations on
on one of these empirical landscapes and
then you see
that when the population size is you
know so that n
n times u population size times mutation
rate
becomes substantially larger than one
then you start crossing valleys and then
these these monotonic pathways are not
relevant anymore so then the population
tends to go
off somewhere else we haven't done this
for the for the sort of weekly
deleterious ones
now in terms of analyzing a pathways in
this more general case of course you
know in principle you could take
you could take your landscape and you
could for example impose a
kind of tolerance and say i tolerate
epsilon
fitness decrease and then you can ask
how does the statistics of the past
change as you take
epsilon to zero so that that's i think a
well-defined problem we haven't done
that but i think it's
it might be interesting to look at that
it just seems like that might near
the the success of the random strategy
for searching these
long paths maybe yes yes that's fine
yeah
okay well i guess um